the Joe Rogan experience yeah no no I
love them absolutely yeah how about
motorcycles I don't [ __ ] with them I was
about to get one I had a bunch of took a
bunch of lessons and I was going for my
license and then two friends wiped out
oh well yeah and got pretty significant
accidents and one guy that I know got
hit by a car by an old man who ran a red
light and t-boned him and sent him
flying into the air and snapped his
femur no that that that would turn you
off I've been riding since I was 19 and
you ride in LA I can ride anywhere but I
prefer to ride in the country up north
in Canada you know or I'm living that
way you live these days a half and a
half here half there half there a little
more in the States because of the travel
with the ban on that but I I'm there
with my dad in Canada a lot and we have
the old family farm but the with the
cotton farm house and I've got sorry
well let's say lets me say that it's
there's residual energy from the people
who've lived there in the past so you
hear footsteps and voices and creaks and
doors closing in that and many people
about experiences in itself there's a
reason why people don't want to live in
a house where people were murdered no
one was killed in that farmhouse right
many people pass there but even that
weird that weirds people out but
absolutely if you have a house where
people were murdered and this is why
there's laws you have to dislike the old
I had to divulge DJ uh it wasn't because
of a murder but when I sold our house in
Los Angeles we lived in mama Casas old
estate and order Wilson Drive and she
sold it to Beverly D'Angelo and she's
been on the celebrity ghost show talking
about the spirits that were in that
house what happens uh you know jewelry
will hop around the table shapes will be
seen you'll feel a touch in the shoulder
that kind of thing the staff felt it and
I had an experience one night where
something got into bed with me I was
alone
went on there but I just figured well in
my you [ __ ] a ghost I think I was
being come on to there but anyway cube
clip that house and Aykroyd [ __ ] a
ghost well or did try to come on to me
and I didn't refuse it's so you resisted
him you know what I just dug 'old up
next to it and went to sleep I phoned
with it I did I felt a shape I looked
and saw the dissection I saw the
depression in the mattress and I felt
the shame he like felt a form next to me
and I know I know
no no not that night I was working on a
picture and went to bed early
I was alone now you're laying alone in
bed and you're working on a film I'm
lying there was something that I've been
working down at Universal
I don't maybe dragnet or something like
that okay see you working on drag men
alone in bed and then there's like a
wait next I feel a wait next to me I
turned I like up the person is like I
saw the depression there were two yes
and I and there were two spirits that
might have been there maybe mama cast
herself although she died in London and
then there was another guy that
apparently a rumor was he died of a drug
overdose at a party and they buried him
in the hillside and my daughter saw him
walking with a little red-haired girl
down the hall once and and and you know
we think that he might have been there
but anyway when we sold the house to
Beverly there was a right in the
California real estate document that we
had to sign by law you have to divulge
any unusual activity in the house so I
had to sign a clause in there that said
yes at the beginning of our tenure in
the house we did have experience yeah so
she bought the house anyway she's still
there she's very happy you had to sign
papers that said you had unusual active
you sell a house in California you will
look in every real estate contract there
will be a clause that you must report
unusual activity so that is the status
of state recognized what if you what's
that what if you do acid in the house
well I can tell you about something
unusual active well that's unusual
activity that you're doing that's not
external but that California you know
just that the state of California
requires that in their realist
documents it's it's pretty compelling
evidence that there's something going on
or compelling evidence that people are
paranoid they want people well I think
most sand spirits also have have reality
I think you think so I believe so tell
me about this thing you're laying down
in bed so you're about to go to sleep
sleep everything's good and I and I feel
this depression I feel this something
Anna are you asleep yet not asleep no no
I just turned out the light and I look
and I see this depression and then I go
well what am I gonna do about this am I
gonna leap up screaming no I rolled over
and I just kind of novel up against it
and and went to sleep and I slept with
like a baby slept like a baby
so there's a scene in the Ghostbusters
movie where I'm in I'm lying down in an
old fort and then this ghost hovers over
me and in the director's cut I think the
belt comes off and the pants come down
whoa so sex with ghost he didn't get
nervous you know I may have been so
tired I may have been so resolved and
resigned I thought you know what there's
no point in panicking there it is yeah
so that's you do you just accept it yes
that's right I just accept it that's a
way to go man
I mean why fight it it's spiritual it's
true it's true
so did you smell it no no smell just
just sense out the weight felt the
weight and saw the depression and then
when I feel anything on your body I did
I found the form yes I did I felt a form
next to me when I knuckle DUP push away
I did not did you push against I
actually kind of wanted to see what it
felt like if there was something there
and I did feel something there I was a
little feminine or masculine it felt
masculine paro you were cuddling with a
dude like a dead biker maybe I don't
know it was the guy who died in the
hills
I don't know could be I don't wanted
friendship you know this male or female
they say the old days men used to just
sleep together
they're just actually sleep sleep like
well you know there's yes there's a
there's a at Davis and Abraham Lincoln
Lincoln yeah we're partners and they
were law partners and they slept in the
same bed many times when they were on
the road yeah I was probably cold as
[ __ ] back then it was hard back to room
that bar the world yeah yeah I just have
a couple blankets and your stay heated
together yeah so when you woke up in the
morning did you feel refreshed or
violated I had slept beautifully I woke
up and maybe better than ever
pretty good yeah I mean I told some
people about the experience and mmm when
there were people that worked in the
house and that were there and then that
you know the living and that that knew
there was something going on but they
knew nothing like the venue and a ghost
had something happening after I told
them yeah so they knew something was
going on well because they had been
they've hear the Stairmaster going by
itself
the exercise the Google exercise it
apparently yeah and and a hand on the
shoulder then the sighting my daughter
had then you know other little things
like jewelry dancing on the table we
knew something was going on in that
house yeah so you're you're a hundred
percent in on ghosts I am